ja diese woche war gamescom der perfekte
ort für gamer görtz wie kelly und milch
hunderte menschen auf engstem raum da
werden wir youtube super stars natürlich
schneller kann also zumindest kelly
kelly ist so dass sich alle mal mit
ihrem foto machen
und wenn dann endlich jemand ein bild
mit mir möchte kommt kelly und zerstört
diesen moment im super special
vip-bereich ging auch schon die post ab
und kelly hat sich nur für die süßen
jungs interessiert und ich mich für die
süßen keks man die waren aber auch so
lecker so lecker dass selbst kelly die
süßen jungs rausgeschmissen hat um zu
futtern es gab aber auch gesundes essen
und noch mehr kuchen und noch mehr essen
es ist natürlich auch sehr wichtig auf
so einer veranstaltung die kontakte zu
seinen arbeitskollegen zu pflegen und
tamina hatte richtig bock drauf
kelly hatte sich dann ganz kurz mal
verliebt und fragte sich dann warum wir
überhaupt hier sind genau natürlich muss
man auf der gamescom auch die neuen
games ausprobieren
[Musik]
und weil man sich dort für jedes spiel
viel zu lange anstellen muss haben wir
ein eigenes spiel erfunden wie youtube
ab heute auf der gamescom
[Musik]
hallo ich mache ein linie handeln will
wer findet vom 24
zu hause
wir sind noch nie
[Musik]
und ich war zwei millionen
die spielregeln sind ganz einfach man
läuft einfach auf der gamescom herum und
versucht so viele self ist mit juden zu
machen wie nur möglich und somit machten
wir uns auf den weg der ungefähr drei
meter lang war denn wir sind ja immer
noch youtube super-stars kelly fand den
erster you tube tent of blood
meine damen und herren und mit diesem
eher als unfairen ersten punkt sind wir
weiter gezogen nur damit kelly gleich
danach den zweiten punkt machen konnte
ich bin ja ich wollte sich lieblich
kelly kelly schatten bekommt man aber
nie einen sonnenbrand
[Musik]
in der zeit in der calle diese ganzen
service war kann ich eigentlich die zeit
nutzen um zu punkten aber ich sehe
einfach mitspielen keiner kennt aber
auch echt mehr als ich wir gingen weiter
und ich fand meinen ersten youtuber
schrägstrich synchronsprecher
schrägstrich switch streamer level läuft
die süßeste perle im ozean kelly hat das
aber gar nicht gelebt werden sie hat
fans mit ihrem autogramm als tattoo man
während sie gerade damit angeben wollte
traf sie schon den nächsten youtube aber
der punkt zählt natürlich nicht wir
haben eine pause von unserem spiel
gemacht um unser hart verdientes youtube
superstar manny auszugeben und dabei
kamen wir zu den mystery boxen waren
hellauf begeistert so viele gaming merge
artikel und was fanden wir zwei
[Musik]
endlich hatte ich meine perfekte halle
gefunden vergesst die neuen games und
das essen konsum ist das einzige was
mich glücklich macht wir waren wie im
rausch und wussten nicht dass das beste
noch vor uns liegt
[Musik]
kelly erklärte mir dass wir mit so einem
kissen niemals einen freund finden
würden und und schloss uns gegen den
kauf doch im cosplay village dance auf
haben wir gelernt wie wir mit den
richtigen moves den partner fürs leben
finden können ja und dann hat die alte
hat ihren dritten youtuber gefunden
dieser bestand zwar nicht aus pappe aber
konsumierte diese sicherlich
[Musik]
es war spät wir haben zwei stunden
bilder gemacht und das essen in
kombination mit meinem kater haben mich
in einen seltsamen zustand gebracht die
letzte kraft nutzen wir um mit unseren
übertriebenes schicken outfits zu posen
und meiner of wight tasche dessen preis
ich erst danach gebündelt habe machte
mir kopfschmerzen vielleicht lag es aber
auch an der musik
[Musik]
over and out